i'm thrilled you know the snp has
increased its share of the vote
increased the number of councillors we
are the largest party in more councils
today than we were yesterday we've won
the election and we've won the election
by a country mile i think it's the
eighth consecutive
election win under my leadership of the
snp all after 15 years in government so
it is a stupendous result for the snp
and sends the clearest possible message
to boris johnson in the tories we later
say that they have a result in glasgow
given their improvement labour are off
the canvas in this election do you think
well from what i
gather the snp is still the largest
party in glasgow we have under the
brilliant leadership of susan aitken
retained the city of glasgow with more
seats and more votes as i understand in
terms of the latest tally i've seen and
labour through the kitchen sink at
glasgow and they have benefited hugely
from the massive collapse in the tory
vote and yet they still can't defeat the
snp so i think there's some reflection
perhaps needed on labour's behalf there
look i understand labour will at sea
moving back into second place in
scotland as
a a bright spot they haven't had many of
those in in recent years but they're
still you know i think some what 12 13
percentage points behind the snp
so i'm interested in the snp result
after 15 years in government we have won
another election not marginally we have
won the election overwhelmingly and let
me congratulate my councillors and
activists in every part of the country
who have campaigned tirelessly in the
last weeks and months and i think you
know the tories in particular in
scotland have suffered a devastating
result and i think there is lots of
thinking uh on the part of douglas ross
that is going to be necessary what do
you think of the police investigation
into kirsten possibly breaking lockdown
rules it's a police investigation and as
you know it would be entirely wrong and
inappropriate for me to comment any
further on that while it is ongoing what
should douglas ross do now
like that's what douglas was to
determine although i suspect having seen
some of the comments from his own
colleagues over the course of the day it
may be a decision to take out of his
hands there's clearly deep unhappiness
at his leadership um you know he has
shown
really really poor judgment in the last
few weeks the calling for boris johnson
to resign when it looked as if the
tories were going to kick boris johnson
out and you know trying to suggest that
was a really big brief thing to do and
then when that changed allowing himself
to be hold back into line just shows a
lack of consistency and resolve
resolving a real lack of leadership i
mean this result is terrible for the
scottish tories now it's for them to
decide where they go from here if you
don't mind i'm going to go in and
celebrate with my own counselors here